hi I'm Sean Carroll I'm a theoretical
physicist here at the California
Institute of Technology I've been
challenged to explain dimensions to five
different levels the idea of a dimension
sometimes in pop culture is
misunderstood like there's an extra
place you can go a mystical dimension or
something like that to a physicist or a
mathematician a dimension is just a
direction you can go in up down left
right forward backward do you and me we
think there's three dimensions around us
but then physicists start talking about
extra dimensions how can you hide them
you know where might they be I'm hopeful
that we'll learn something at each level
we're gonna talk about some science do
you like science yes a lot oh very good
you come to the right place so we're
gonna think about physics have you heard
the word physics before do you know what
that is what's your idea what physics is
I'm not so sure okay I just think of
physics as you know the study of
everything what stuff is what stuff does
so today we're going to talk about space
and in particular the idea of dimensions
have have you heard about dimensions I
think I mean I ain't enough 3d printing
3d printing good no I own keys the size
all I have to do with the shape but you
know what 3d means it's free dimensional
three dimensional as opposed to what is
ordinary printing so ordinary printing
would be 2 d what do you say when
something is one-dimensional what's an
example of something it's
one-dimensional a line is the perfect
example because it's one thing that's
straight right so here's some toys we're
gonna build some dimensions right so
what would you say about this that's 1
exactly it's not really one dimensional
everything has to be one or two
dimensional before it's free dimensional
and how would you find yourself like if
someone said where are you like could
you use some words or ideas to say where
you are on that line I think I would be
a maybe
there since I'm facing it but here's
what I wanted to think about if I say
I'm at this point on the line I could
translate that into saying I'm at the
three-centimeter point if I were here I
via the four-centimeter point the
five-centimeter point right so every
point every location on our little line
has its own unit as its own unit has one
number we need one number to tell you
where we are that's one dimension that's
what it means to be one dimensional I
only need to tell you one number to
figure out where we are because if it's
like a sphere you kind of have to start
using points there you go exactly we're
gonna build a little two dimensional
space you wanna do it you wanna do the
honors here why don't you put those two
lines together if you make it mental is
this a corner
exactly another way is if you are two
spacing between is an angle I think you
should be in this chair and he should be
explaining this to me you're much better
than this than I am
yeah so those are the dimensions that's
how we think about dimensions remember
we just needed one number to find
ourselves on the line we need two
numbers to find ourselves on the plane I
think that would be an X or Y axis there
you go so do you think we could have
more than three dimensions 3d is the
maximum of dimensions for shapes well as
far as we know this is why physicists
think about things we don't know about
we're wondering whether it could be
extra dimensions you've never seen that
are tinier than atoms so okay so what
have you learned what do you know about
dimensions now how do you think about
dimensions in a slightly different way
than you did before so at least
everything has a certain dimension yeah
do you think he'd be excited a physicist
said that they found extra dimensions of
space that would be the news would be
spreaded around the world rocket I think
so I think you're right all right Hank
we want you to you know keep up studying
learn a lot of math and physics and help
us discover new dimensions someday does
that sound like a fun idea yeah
do you like science doesn't think about
what kind of science I like biology and
computer science all right you're in the
wrong place we're not gonna be talking
about biology computer science so we
want to talk about the idea of
dimensions the other dimension is how
you define dimensions I guess I don't
know how to exactly define it but I know
like the first floor right you know the
difference between like one dimension
dimensions three dimensions etc so let's
do a little experiment here so there's
one dimension I'll give that to you now
here's here's your task I'm gonna give
you another dimension and I'm gonna ask
hold those two things at right angles to
each other it's easy to do so there's no
trace here I'm not trying to pull you
here okay now this will be slightly
trickier I'm going to give you this I
want you to hold all three of them at
right angles to all the others at the
same time there you go so what that's
doing is when you had just two that was
describing a two-dimensional plane right
like the two things pick out a plane the
three things pick out all three
dimensional space now we'll give you one
more I'm gonna ask you to hold that
fourth one so that it's at a right angle
to all the other three at the same time
all right now I am can't be done you
can't do it so we just experimentally
proved that space is three-dimensional
that's sort of what it means to be
three-dimensional that there are three
different directions you can move in and
there's not four or five or six
directions you can move in okay there
you go three dimensional space right
mm-hmm
so have you thought about using
coordinates in three dimensions yeah I
was actually doing SAT prep there you go
it showed like the x y&z axis as well
that's right so that's exactly what
these would be have you heard that there
are other coordinate systems other than
XYZ no but we could also say how far we
are away from the center just the
distance and then the angle that our
little line makes with that's a B X ax
yeah so that's a different way of giving
you two numbers and locating yourself
and we called
polar coordinates is a different
coordinate system well we want to do as
physicist is look for extra dimensions
can you imagine can you think of any way
that there could be extra dimensions
time time yes Einstein that said that we
can think of time as a fourth dimension
and that's a very fascinating thing that
we could talk about all by itself but
what about space what about the solar
system like if you wanted to tell me
where a certain star was in the sky do
you know what
how we do that I have no idea it's it's
exactly the same thing as latitude and
longitude but we put coordinates on the
sky so astronomers call them right
Ascension and declination which are two
terrible words but basically you've seen
you know on the globe where you draw
latitude and longitude what it looks
like yeah there are the peals of an
orange kind of thing right yeah so you
can define something as well you know
how high above a certain location on
earth it is but the earth is rotating
and revolving around the Sun so we have
to define separate celestial coordinates
so there's like mold how many dimensions
would there be we don't know you know
the optimistic view is that there are
six but the thing is some of them might
be really really really really really
small like way too small for us to ever
see yeah and some of them might be
medium sized that hopefully we can see
okay so since it's all theoretical like
this could not be three dimension and
this is sort of the state of uncertainty
that physicists are stuck living out you
know honestly out there if you go out
onto campus and talk to the physicists
half of them will say probably extra
dimensions exist and have them say no
that's just nonsense okay after all this
yeah someone comes up to you on the
street and says what's a dimension oh
man I mean I guess what I've learned
today is just that there are not just
three dimensions or at least we think I
mean everything's theoretical it's all
just really kind of confusing that's
right and you know if they're still
bugging you you can just like give them
some sticks and act as we're together
and that would shut them up yeah
where do you go to school and what do
you study I'm gonna be a sophomore from
ona college and I study math and physics
Oh math and physics okay what kind of
physicists do you want to be you know I
really don't know I like theory and
experimental so it's kind of tough for
me to say usually if it's math and
physics you end up as a theoretical
physicist right yeah experimental one so
our theme here today is dimensions and
so this is great that you have some math
background some mathematicians think
about dimensions in a different way yeah
so how would you explain to you know
your friends who are not math and
physics majors like what is it dimension
yourself
my first intuitive thought is water like
the coordinates you know so if we were
looking at things we're looking like a
dot that's like one or a line rather
that's one dimensional because we can
only measure it one way but now if we
look at like a square then we're
increasing like that so it's like all
basically the what coordinates we can
use to measure something that's exactly
right and so you've heard of space time
yeah being four-dimensional right now in
some sense that's kind of trivial to you
and me because of course you have space
which is three-dimensional you have time
which is one dimensional so space-time
is four-dimensional but it didn't turn
out it didn't occur to anyone that that
was a sensible way to talk until really
relativity this is the crucial thing
right is that what Einstein realized is
that sure there's both time and space
but how we divide space time into time
and space can be different for different
people and really there's a real sense
in which four-dimensional space-time is
kind of a generalization of
three-dimensional space and I think to
really explain this we're gonna need a
blackboard okay let's bring what it
all right think about relativity is that
they really want you to think of
space-time as one four-dimensional thing
right it's kind of like space it's not
just three dimensions of space in one
dimension of time why though why this is
a very good question so let's just start
with space right you know a little bit
about space so here's my simple-minded
way of drawing space two dimensions
because that's how many I can draw on
the blackboard let's say x and y and
what is special about space there's many
things but one is that if I have you
know a curve or a path between two
points there's a distance that you can
calculate right and the distance between
those two points doesn't depend on your
coordinates it doesn't depend on whether
you're in radial coordinates or
Cartesian coordinates or whatever I'm
allowed to imagine a curve that does
something like this between those two
points and if I were a person walking on
that curve I would have an a domitor
with me maybe and I would know you you
would know even without having done that
this path has always going to be longer
than that there's a formula I thank you
mrs. theorem it tells you what the
shortest distance path is that's the
point the physicalness of what is real
is the distance along a certain curve so
space-time is like that that's why it is
useful to think about space okay so let
me draw space-time is how we usually
draw it I'll just say X but all of space
is condensed this one direction and this
is time okay so if you're a little
person you start at some event so you
start you're located somewhere in space
somewhere the three coordinates of space
and whether you like it or not you're
moving through space-time just by
getting older yeah when people ask me
can you travel through time I say yes
yesterday I traveled 24 hours into the
future and Here I am you know the day
later so that's just this okay you're
moving through time like that so what
Einstein says is look I can travel
through space-time in different ways
like I could hop in a rocket ship and
fly out and then fly back and then I can
meet you there so this is a different
trajectory through space-time right yeah
and it's almost exactly like the space
story the space story says there's a
distance distance is different along
different
Irv's Einstein says there's something
that measures the length of these curves
and we call it the proper time it is
literally the time that you would read
on your wristwatch so it's kind of like
our like fundamental time I got face
time well kind of what Einstein wants to
get across this there's no such thing as
fundamental like there's the universe is
time this big letter T that might you
know tell you how old the universe is
but then every individual has a clock
with them and they measure their own
time depending on how they're moving
through the universes and the crucial
difference is the time is not the same
for this person who stayed behind and
sat in their chair and this person who
zoomed out there why is that this one is
shorter than there is what we call a
metric on space time and when we talk
about Euclidean space versus a curved
space versus a sphere or something
that's a different metric and space-time
has its own metric which says the
following thing that the path between
two events in space-time that is a
straight line will always be the longest
time I see okay that's the difference
all right so what when I had this idea
Oh gravity could be related to the
curvature of space-time he did some
equations okay so he got it that's a
long story will satisfy what he figured
out was that rather than gravity living
on top of space-time it's a
manifestation of the curvature of
space-time so when you have like the
earth the Sun the moon they cause a
gravitational field they're actually
warping the space-time around them
they're giving it a different geometry
would it be if I had like a spring off
or not a spring like a like a sheet and
I dropped like a book in the sheet
curves down yeah exactly if you if you
had a sheet that was originally flat and
you know you sent a marble on it would
go in a straight line then if you put
something on it so it warps it that
marble is now gonna be deflected I see
Einstein says the gravity is just like
that I see but there are no straight
lines because space-time itself is
curved so do you think if you had to
explain relativity what would you say I
think I'd go with like the kind of like
the Train paradox let's say I'm
stationary and someone's moving past me
on the train they think they're
stationary on the train like they think
that they're not accelerating but if
they start walking through the train
cars then they are accelerating in their
frame but then from my outside frame
where I'm completely removed
I see they're accelerating so I guess
that relativity is all about perspective
I guess in a way yeah that's right and
it goes exactly back to what we drew on
the board and we're how those two people
in the Train and on the ground would
divide space-time up differently you
have to space in time
that's pretty good yeah it's a lot of
fun stuff to talk about so observational
cosmology so like what would he look at
so I work on two ground-based surveys
and the optical and we're basically
trying to make huge maps of the universe
so that we can study dark energy I'm
sure you've heard about extra dimensions
a little bit I've heard it yeah I'm
thinking about the idea that there might
be more than three dimensions of space
what is your impression of theoretical
physicists who think about things like
extra dimensions of space that they
haven't ever seen I get a little scared
cuz I think oh how can you prove these
theories right one theory I've heard of
I don't know if this fits in with that
is bubble universes it's not an extra
dimension does that fit into that or is
that something it does in fact one way
that different universes might sort of
be created and be different from each
other is that different universes could
have effectively different numbers of
dimensions like we have three dimensions
around us but there's people out there
aliens who could live in five
dimensional universes and are each of
those dimensions do are they governed by
the same laws of physics or is there
like a separate lagrangian for each
universe yeah how does that work we
think that it would be you know all this
is incredibly speculative and we don't
know for sure
but the idea is that there is some deep
down underlying laws that are universal
and the same but they show up
differently so they appear different so
the specific particles and forces and
masses would be completely different in
different parts of the multiverse okay
why in the world would you think that
there are extra dimensions right so
you've heard of string theory I have so
the string theory is basically a theory
of quantum gravity mm-hmm so we have
quantum mechanics right the theory of
you know atoms and so forth and how
those work and then we have gravity and
gravity doesn't seem to fit in it's the
one force of nature that we can't really
easily fit into this quantum mechanical
so string theory is one of the best
right ideas that's the good news the bad
news is that it only seems to work if
space-time is ten dimensional so you
would say well then it's wrong it can't
be right space-time is not 10
dimensional space-time is four
dimensional you've observed that but
instead we say if space-time looks four
dimensional to us but string theory
which might be the best theory we have
of quantum gravity says it must be 10
dimensional maybe we could hide those
extra six dimensions somehow so here's
how we could get lucky we could imagine
that there are extra dimensions of space
that are curled up somehow that are so
small that we can't see them this is
actually an old idea it goes back to
Colusa and klein right after general
relativity was invented in 1915 but
there's a more recent idea that says
there could actually be relatively large
extra dimensions there could be extra
dimensions that are actually that big
like a millimeter across that you would
not have noticed but here's the new
exciting idea so let's imagine okay
there's a piece of paper but let's
imagine this is our entire world so in
other words our real world is three
dimensional but let's imagine that we're
just idealizing it down to two
dimensions so we all live here you and I
live here but let's imagine that we're
embedded in this bigger space so there
are extra dimensions that are actually
big ok let's imagine that when I say we
live on this three dimensional world
what I mean is imagine that the
particles that you and I are made of
right the quarks the leptons the
electrons and everything all the forces
we know about electromagnetism the weak
nuclear force the strong nuclear force
imagine that they can't leave this
surface this is what will we call a
brain BR ane have you heard this word
before right yes do you know where it
comes from
no from membranes you know we have lines
one dimension we have two-dimensional
surfaces so if you have a line that is a
vibrating physical thing you call it a
string right right if you have a
two-dimensional surface that vibrates
and is a physical thing we call that a
membrane membrane theory goes back it
never was as popular as string theory
but it's been around for a while but if
you have extra dimensions of space then
you can have three-dimensional vibrating
things and four-dimensional vibrating
things so how do these strings give rise
to things like mass
in charge and basically give us the
properties of the particles we see well
basically the strings are the particles
that we see it's exactly the same thing
as we said you know for the straw if you
look at it far away it looks
one-dimensional a little loop of string
so a little one-dimensional circle that
is vibrating if you look at it from very
very far away it just looks like a
particle
so in string theory an electron is a
little string a photon is a little
string so is string theory part of what
they call the grand unified theory is
it's supposed to be the the last thing
that sort of unifies all the forces
together yeah string theory is even
better
so the phrase grand unified theory was
coined in the 1970s for theories that
joined electricity and magnetism so a
good string theory is gravity plus a
grand unified theory that's even better
is the theory of everything what would
you tell a friend of yours if they asked
you what dimensions are what extra
dimensions are what a brain is so we
have three spatial dimensions a brain is
sort of the next level so a brain is a
higher dimensional object that vibrates
through space that's right and we could
live there the world we see around us
the three dimensions of space around us
could reflect the fact that we are
somehow stuck on a three dimensional
brain trying to escape it was really
cool to learn about strings and brains
and how looking at gravity on small
scales is actually connected to what I
do and looking at gravity on these
cosmological scales and it's definitely
something I'm going to think about in my
research you're a string theorist so
tell us like what kind of string theory
you do what it means to be you string
theorists one of the things that's key
in the whole story of string theory is
the piece of it that talks about quantum
theories of gravity so I'm very excited
about what happens to space-time what
does even mean at the quantum level cool
so do you think a lot about extra
dimensions in your everyday life yes I
do and so when you think about extra
dimensions you put them together with
brains and different fields wrapping
around the extra dimensions and so forth
right yes you know a lot of people a lot
of string theorists they care a lot
about all the different ways in which we
could hide the extra dimensions as
someone who cares about cosmology I want
to start asking why are the extra
dimensions small at all how did
happen is this something you think about
yourself yes well ultimately we'd like
to understand the observable universe if
string theory turns out to be the thing
that the universe cares about we'd like
to know with all of these possibilities
of the in string theory how do we get
the one that looks like the world we
live in the thing I want to talk about
is this paper I wrote with Matt Johnson
and Lisa Randall where we realized
there's another way to compactify extra
dimensions spontaneously dynamically if
you imagine starting with this big piece
of paper you couldn't wrap up everything
but within some region of space you
could make a tube okay right and down
there in the tube it looks like you're a
long thing that is compactified in one
direction and infinitely extend in the
other direction so there's one less
macroscopic dimension of space okay I
think that sounds plausible to you it
sounds like fun what I would immediately
ask is whether the large dimensions come
from in the first place is that
something you address or you just assume
that large debate all the dimensions are
large as a starting point yeah so we
certainly assume that they're all large
as a starting point and it's worse than
that
so in our paper we imagine you start in
de sitter space you start in a universe
with no matter no anything like that
just empty space but with an energy that
is positive and all the dimensions are
large but where do they come from it was
always there why why not okay this is
replacing one prejudice for the
different prejudice I would say that we
shouldn't be prejudiced one way or the
other just a large you know 10 or 11
dimensions with the cosmological
constant doesn't seem like a fundamental
starting point it's it sounds like there
needs to be something to underlie that
but it's a fun scenario yeah so let me
tell you a little bit more about the
scenario so you know there are black
holes good right I've heard of them
there are black brains as well why don't
you explain to us what a black brain is
well in some ways it's very much like a
black hole and that you have far away
from it you have these large just you
know flat dimensions as you move in
there's there's something in the
it has itself higher dimensions and so
because physicists love to joke
they thought well it's like a membrane
but it can have many different
dimensions let's use P to stand in for
those number of dimensions and so they
call them P brain yeah I've been trying
to explain them to lower levels and they
always look at me like I like your a
little bit or is this the real thing
that they use yes it is the real thing
they use we study these brains in de
sitter space and so we what we found is
that there are black brain solutions
which instead of having a singularity
inside our non singular and stable and
compactified is this a familiar thing I
know things like this have been
discussed yeah yeah so a lot of the
brains that are relevant for studying
things to do with anti-de sitter
spacetime x' in various dimensions
actually start out as these non singular
type brains and then you find in the
core there's actually an entity sitter
spacetime right
imagine that rather than going down to a
point it just ask some totes to some
fixed radius and continues infinitely
far down but then you can ask okay what
about the rest of the university have
like some sphere some two dimensions
compactified and the balance between the
cosmological constant and the
electromagnetic field keeps it at a
distance but then the other dimensions
the transverse dimensions don't need to
be anti-de sitter they can have either
positive 0 or negative cosmological
constant so you can basically get any
sort of cosmological solution times a
compactified sphere is it that these
have the lowest action of all the things
that could possibly all the possible
solutions I guess I mean maybe maybe you
think otherwise again or maybe we could
change my mind I think that as long as
it can happen it will happen some of the
time right you mean the one of the
things that could happen so I mean
obviously you know we know one of them
baby I stole that from Kenna Reeves I'm
afraid someone probably wrote it for you
so it's possible that if you do have
this starting point of an empty de
sitter space with positive cosmos
constant some field flying around you
inevitably get a multiverse it just
happened you know it's just part of
quantum nucleation two different things
and then maybe you need to explain why
we live in this universe rather than
some other one via the anthropic
principle or something like that so how
does how does our kind of you know
Tech old-fashioned way of making new
universes intersect with the kinds of
things you'd think about well it's
interesting because there's a lot of
activity going on inspired by things we
learned from working in anti-de sitter
space where the cosmological constant
has you know right wrong sign so you
will find that there are a number of
papers as many of which you've probably
read probably you've read more of them
that I have which try then to take
different kinds of brains these extended
solutions or and there many different
kinds doing different things we
understand them well enough now that we
can put them together in various ways
they intersect they dissolve inside each
other they and you do them all in all
sorts of different ways and shows that
you can construct four-dimensional
universes with a cosmological constant
of your desire depending upon how you
did the construction not everyone buys
that there's a big discussion in the
literature right now and if we put aside
for the second the concerns of our
colleagues in other parts of physics and
it's just amongst us chickens what do
you think about the future of cosmology
and string theory and the dynamics of
these extra dimensions I think it's
gonna get way more interesting than then
we're currently able to grapple with
right now and I think there are hints of
it there could be a description of the
physics that might be our early universe
that is like that molecular description
and then from that emerges flat space
times maybe for maybe some mechanism
tells you it's for not something else I
think that's where we're going if the
viewers want to know more about how
space-time can emerge from quantum
mechanics they could read the graphic
novel you just wrote right yes I wrote
in drew a graphic novel called the
dialogues conversations about the nature
of the universe and I just wrote a book
called something deeply hidden about
many worlds quantum mechanics and how
space-time can emerge from it plenty
reading material for the audience out
there excellent
so that was fun
I hope that everyone did learn something
I know that I did it was very nice to
see how the idea of dimensions and space
resonates in different ways with
different people all the way up to
talking to Clifford about the forefront
of modern research I really do think
that we're not done understanding how
dimensions work there are three
dimensions of space why that why not -
why not 27 I think that we really don't
yet have the data or ideas to think
about this but we're creeping up on it
I'm optimistic about progress in the
near future I'm a professor at the
University of Waterloo and I'm a sleep
scientist at UCSF today I've been
challenged to explain lasers to explain
the topic of sleep at five different
levels
[Music]